it's like a great song which is really
hard to do with stand up
to make people want to listen to it
again even when they know what's coming
at the end of this set i remember conan
he always says something really nice but
because i'm i'm incredibly insecure i
always
compare it to things he said to other
people on the
show and i'm like i've heard him say
things really nice
about sets that i was like um that
really wasn't that good
whatever the point is is that he said it
reminded him of bob newhart
and i i had to pinch myself because that
man was my
my um my north star
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome back to
the show they're very funny gary goldman
[Music]
thanks very much i just wanted to uh
recommend a documentary
to everyone and then then i'm gonna go
um
it's about the uh it's about the men and
one woman who abbreviated all 50 states
down to two letters
on my list every year every january one
of my things is
get gary goldman oh and i feel like i
nag you sometimes
no i'm overwhelmed and but we've talked
about it before that i
i i feel like this will sound so
obnoxious but it's it's the truth the
bar is pretty high
so i have to come with something good it
can't be
i almost feel like it can't be just a
collection of good jokes it has to be
one
really long good joke so the premise
which was why do all the states start
with the same
letter and how um difficult
it would have been to abbreviate them
knowing that
that premise was in my notebook and i
had tried it
two years into comedy or or less i can
remember
and every year i would
i used to call it old ironsides because
there's this ship in boston that once a
year they take it out into the harbor
work the barnacles off and and and
it's from like the civil war the war of
1812 and
and you could truck it out every year
make sure it didn't work
and then and then put it back into my
warehouse and
i knew i wanted to hold on to it because
nobody else had that joke i remember the
uh this was 2016.
it was february of 2016. we had a dark
week which is a week that we're not
taping shows
and i went to jeff ross our executive
producer and i told him that i want to
spend a week
and just stay in new york and be able to
bounce around and follow people
and i was working on a set with leonard
dudes and he just texted me he's like
i'm going to be at the seller tonight if
you want to come by so it was like like
a 9 o'clock show we're upstairs in the
bar
and then word reached us that you were
going on stage and so
we all it was like three of us went down
the back stairs but i remember just
sitting in the back in the corner and we
were all just watching you and
i was amazed and you sent me this great
text at the end of the night you
i i think you said do you know anybody
who has a joke about
abbreviating the states um i'd like to
put him on conan
and and that that i mean i
jumped for joy
thanks very much i just wanted to uh
recommend a documentary to everyone and
then
then i'm gonna go um when you do this in
a headlining set how is it different
because
if you're doing a 45 to an hour
saying that you're going to get out of
here that you can't do that when you
first walk out no
it's it's purely for for 10 15 minute
sets it's about the men and one woman
who abbreviated all 50 states down to
two letters
all you have to know for this is that we
have 50 states in america and they each
have a two capital letter abbreviation
but that that wasn't always the case up
until i want to say 1973
and so i will now i read this
description to the documentary and much
like you thought to myself how are they
going to make a 98-minute documentary
about a task that couldn't have taken
more than six minutes to complete
boy was i wrong it was an adventure ups
and downs ins and outs friends became
enemies enemies became friends
they started off they thought it was
going to be easy because alabama led
them into a false sense of security
they said alabama al holy crap this is
easy
we're going to finish before they stop
serving breakfast in the hotel
restaurant
and the boss said guys if we finish
before they stop serving breakfast
breakfast is on me
and then one guy said oh i hope they
have an omelette station
just just for context the omelette
station had just been invented and
it it was sweeping the nation do you
actually
know when the apple station wasn't
invented no absolutely not but i know
that during my lifetime there was no
omelette station
and then later there there was did the
omelet
chef exist on its own at one point yeah
of course the omelet chef was a
it was a separate joke based on the fact
that i loved
omelets but was so intimidated by an
omelet chef
on vacation that i would have my my
girlfriend
at the time go come and get me an omelet
i was so intimidated by the the angry
omelet chef but also
had so much empathy because i thought
about it i was like yeah i wouldn't want
to be the only chef either and this
other guy said you know what i'm not i'm
not comfortable with the omelette
station because i
i feel like the omelet chef resents you
like he didn't want to be the omelet
chef nobody dreams of being omelet chef
he wanted to be the chef chef
now instead of now instead of giving the
orders he's taking the orders from your
stupid wife and your ugly kids
i think one day he's going to snap and i
don't want to be there when it happens
and they were like well why don't you
just get eggs benedict and he said i
don't like holiday sauce
did you just say holiday sauce yeah why
uh cause it's hollandaise you
at this point i think the audience just
forgets
why we're here which i love like
i don't care where we started or if we
ever achieve what you say we're going to
achieve
i'm just enjoying being here in this
hamlet station conversation right i mean
the whole thing with the omelet
chef joke was that it was always very
very weak or as they
say backstage at conan it was soft right
do you sometimes say that about a
joke it was soft so it was never really
a big joke but it was
in joke form and was enough of a
distraction
for the people to forget what we were
doing so that when i go back
to to al as the abbreviation
people like oh man that's that's a uh
that's a weird dude right there and then
the boss said
um guys i hate to be a nudge but could
we get back to abbreviating the states
we still have 49 left
and apologies were made and
understanding was reached and they got
back to abbreviating they said what's
next they said alaska
everybody cool with a.l
can you tell how good of a show it's
going to be
at that laugh right there who's actually
paying attention i knew
that by the time i got to that laugh
from just doing it a hundred
times that i was home free everything
from this point on is
is really i'm not gonna lose them at
this point because it's very
joke heavy i was relieved at at 2 42 as
it turns out
42 is how long you had to wait but
somebody caught it
one man sheepishly raised his hand said
sir i think we might have used that one
before
are you sure i'm pretty sure well let's
check the minutes
[Laughter]
what's up dottie dottie read the minutes
back to us hun
dottie was the wife tracking secretary
every 1970s office had a wisecracking
secretary and this one's name was dottie
and dottie dottie was a pistol you would
love
you she was a real hot ticket dottie
listen to what daddy said they said
dottie read the minutes
how dotty is this he said read the
minutes back to us
this is so dotty and she goes you mean
the minute
i was at a restaurant in new york city
and i overheard a woman
talking to her friend about one of her
zany
exploits and she said how jody is that
and her your friend said so jody and i
just
it was it was like i just cringed and i
was like oh what kind of
people speak of themselves and and they
have a
certain like a uh this is the character
i play in my life
oh daddy
daddy daddy what are we gonna do with
you spank my ass and make me a martini
daddy you're incorrigible now read the
minutes back to us you randy minx
and she said uh it's hollandaise you
at et2 dottie how do you know
shakespeare you don't know hollandaise
that's a paradox
that is such a throwaway line but i
love it so much that you bring
shakespeare into it
this is like completely unnecessary that
again is from
is from college and i mean you must hear
this all the time you
you use by the time you're 25 years into
comedy
you use everything that's ever come
across your
your your brain so what's next arizona
ai there we go we're back on track next
arkansas
that is i think the only time i ever
swore on
on on television like that but
it i mean because i said crap earlier
because you don't want to say i think
you're only allowed one but
i allowed two shits an hour okay so
so i don't want to use it up and also
had conan wanted to use one
at some point then i wouldn't have had
any and it just
when you say on a show that you're
not allowed to say
i mean they're not expecting that
so it just it really
it really worked well and it and it's
it's worth saving it's like one of those
things in a video game you don't want to
use all the power pellets right away you
want to
use it for the for the right moment by
the time they got to maine maryland
massachusetts followed by michigan
minnesota mississippi and missouri
shots were fired they were they were at
each other's throats
so they did what any savvy business
would do they hired a consultant they
brought in a contractor
i'm sorry not a not a contractor a
contractor a man
a man who made words smaller by
combining them or apostrophizing them i
will say that that was
one of those those mistakes that i made
one night that
wound out being funny because i used to
just go right to they
hired a contractor and and one time i
said it wrong
and it was funnier saying it wrong so i
i
kept saying it wrong and and it was
it was helpful it's just one of those
lucky mistakes this guy was the best he
was a legend
within that world like you wouldn't know
his name
but you know his work like he wrote such
timeless classics as o'clock
many years ago people would say it's
nine of the clock it's 10 of the clock
this visionary said we don't need the
that is so much fun to say we don't need
the
sometimes you say things you know like
nobody is going to like this and then
when they do like it it's it's such a
great
it's such a great feeling because it's
also
it's also really really silly really
silly
he also wrote would have could have
should have the holy trinity of regret
he wrote uh he wrote the very very
innovative weed of he looked at we would
have and said i can do that in half the
letters
he was not without controversy he also
wrote the most controversial contraction
of all time he wrote won't
people said how are you going to
abbreviate will not not use a single l
and he said watch me
are you saying i won't be able to do it
i just did
thank you very much
you had a different closer yeah long
story short they made it on time for
breakfast but it
it seemed contrived and and cute what i
love is that
you're you never you never answer you
never continue finish they finish the
conversation the explanation of the 50
seats i mean i guess i owe
christopher nolan for the for that
because he made it so that you really
didn't have to tie up all the all the
loose ends the people who wanted the
loose ends
tightened up those people are are not
capable of
of abstract thinking and and so it's
it's
an opportunity to be judgmental
[Music]
demo therapy called this the bohemian
rhapsody of stand-up acts
oh wow i think it's more of the the jump
around
because if you remember queen had more
more
hits than bohemian rhapsody but that's a
that's a terrific
compliment eric shepard says i've been
saying woulda coulda shoulda my
whole life but never had the imagination
available to refer to it as the holy
trinity of regret
that was epic wow oh that's really
that's really nice that was a late ad
that was probably the
last few months of its of its run before
the
before the show i mean the the thing
that
that is always fun with a joke is is to
put your
your world view and your neuroses into
the
into the cracks of the joke so that if
you were really trying to analyze this
person
you would the whole thing is really a
cry for help and attention and
and and um my my
neuroses are on on display but it was it
was appealing enough to me that i
i left it in there
you have been such a supporter of
comedians i get more emails from you
about other comedians and it makes my
job so much easier because
if they pass the gary test it's like
okay well i know there are some
comedians who close the door behind them
entertainers who do that and i always
resented it with
with great vigor and i
never wanted to be that guy because i'm
i'm reliant on so many comedians who
who brought me along and and recommended
me and talked me
up and you have one that you work with
brian kiley was it was a guy who
who talked me up and brought me along
for for so many years and
it's just it would be the the height of
selfishness if i if i want to try to do
that and also
it the thing they don't tell you about
altruism
is that it it feels terrific there has
to be
some sort of evolution in us that
helping
other other mammals makes us feel really
good
i think it's so important in in stand up
is is that where
we're artists and and we should try to
push the
the form further further ahead and and
you do that by
by touting people who who you you also
get to sort of curate your taste
so i get to say this is the type of
comedian i want to see on conan
it's not hyperbole to say that that
that appearance changed my my career
significantly and and
one thing that i that i wanted to
mention was that
it it got some some notice when it
first ran and then sometime between nine
months and a year later
patton oswalt shared it on
on facebook and that made it go
viral i think and and that was
what made it so that i i noticed
more people at my shows and once you
have your own audience you're able to do
more jokes like that so it's it's just
built on itself so i'm i'm eternally
grateful for that